scp-682 vs scp-017  could the shadow person be up to the  task of finally consigning the  hard-to-destroy reptile to eternal  darkness let's find out the shadow  person is a small figure roughly the  size and shape of a human child with the  ability to absorb other entities and  make them disappear by simply coming  into contact with their shadows it  consumed a tissue sample from scp-682  with no issues so the tests proceeded  however during the full test  scp-682 roared in a horrible rage  causing  scp-017 to stumble and retreat back to  the corner of the cell it refused to  come near scp-682  to this day it's unclear whether the  sound hurt 017 or merely frightened it